leute ich bin am 26 im heide park auf
dem xxl kuba der will nämlich treffen
und kommt auf jeden fall können wir
bisschen daran ließ dass vielleicht mal
das ein oder andere karussell besteigen
er ist eventuell auch mit dabei deswegen
kommt auf jeden fall rom wird hammer
tickets gibt's und in der video
beschreibung ist auf alles vergünstigt
und so also steckt es auf jeden fall ab
wenn die aus der umgebung kommt und ich
freue mich auch heute nicht erschienen
war
falls wir super kommt einfach aus ganz
deutschland erinnern dass wir das wollte
ich sagen dass wir der oberhammer
das wird krass
hey leute was klappt jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video ich habe heute mal
wieder erst nochmal christian dabei und
jetzt kommt ein motorrad auf jeden fall
wieder wunderbar es wird ja irgendwie
immer wenn ein video machen ist schönes
wetter von damals gedacht dass er wieder
auf jeden fall haben wir uns für heute
gedacht kommen wir machen das mal so und
zwar hat sich jeder von uns vier fragen
überlegt ja dem anderen stellen wird und
wenn man die frage richtig beantwortet
bleibt man verschont und wenn man die
falschparker machen ist die rechtslage
klar
ja ja ich würde sagen wir wollen gar
nicht eingeladen und legen direkt mal
los und wenn es euch gefällt vielleicht
kann man da auch eine zweite folge von
machen dann lasst auf jeden fall den
samstag nach oben da und dann wissen wir
bescheid
genau danach das sams ab was auch wir
fangen an mit der ersten frage ich habe
wir haben jeweils zwei perverse fragen
und zwei normale fragen oder hast du
dich schon auf jeden fall egal
nun ist die normalen erst kommt der
normale frage ganz simpel wie alt ist
der älteste mensch geworden der jemals
auf der erde gelebt hat usa 133 jahre b
122 jahre oder c 142 jahre
wenn jemand 132 142 jahr 122 richtig 44
1724 jahre tragen leben lebenstagen
wurde französische oder john colbourne
die älteste frau der welt finde es sehr
gut gemacht
es geht um die wm 2014
in der wii fit minute schoss mario götze
die deutsche nationalmannschaft am sieg
in der 12
1315 tempo oder die 114
ich habe das mir letztens noch auf
youtube hat es entweder die 112 113
ich hab' ich habe wollte erst 112 ok
kommen wir zur nächsten frage und zwar
wie schwer sind die größten größte der
welt soll ich das wissen a 19 kilo 30
kilo oder c 37 kilogramm 30 noch keiner
kein mensch sagen 90 kg duisburg falsch
ist gewaltige 30 kilogramm bei aign die
brüste der us-amerikanischen porno
darstellerin anna hawkins turner auf die
wage ich mal sagen
klein ist der kleinste mensch der jetzt
noch am leben ist circa 54 55 cm b 43 44
cm c48 bis 9 40 zentimeter oder den us
50 bis 51 sind es gibt nur drei auswahl
immer aber ich habe doch gerade auch
über die asse gemacht du hast auch in
der ersten fragen und ich habe
irgendwann bist du ja ok egal wat 108 54
6 cm 15 cm richtige
egal mädchen schrieb ich bin dran
nächste frage passt wie viele abonnenten
habe ich gerade also genau jetzt auf
youtube auf tausender gerundet auf 1101
1000 städte story 305.000 oder 204.000
auf 1104 1000 die kinder nicht dunkel
ich hab jetzt zeigt er doch weiterstadt
so ja ich es kann sein dass ich schon
wieder 300 dazu gewonnen am liebsten
hätte ich hier war doch richtig weil da
komme ich immer hier den glorreichen
sieg heute einen schritt näher und frage
was wurde letztes jahr also welcher
begriff wurde letztes jahr am meisten in
deutschland google.de helene fischer wm
2014 oder die iphone 6 helene fischer
falsch getroffen nur was ist der rekord
für den längsten geschlechtsverkehr drei
stunden also das wort von 66
wissenschaftler hält beobachtet a3 war
live dabei
3 stunden 9 stunden 10 15 stunden 15
du bist so ein guter mann vor allem ich
habe die ganze zeit nur drei
auswahlmöglichkeiten
beim netz mache ich zwei ausnahmen 42 ok
2 aber ich habe es nie wieder so einfach
junge meine frage ist aber auch einfach
welcher fluss ist der größte also der
größte nicht der längste also von dem
die meisten der wasserreichste fluss
oder amazon amazon kameraleute
leider haben wir halt nur dreimal falsch
wir warten kann man jetzt auch nichts
machen
ich hoffe ihr hattet trotzdem spaß beim
anschauen wenn ja dann lasst es uns in
den kommentaren als 100 reimann daumen
nach oben hin voll egal ist okay wir
sind wir fällen doch erziehungs wir sind
ok wir sind real racing rebell mit aviv
auf jeden fall wenn ihr wollt
instagram bin ich heute nicht schaden
die beschreibung reinsteckt dass ihr
abschreckt dass ihr habt es eingeblendet
und meinung war auch ein gemeines app
könnt ihr mich gerne ändern ansonsten
würde ich sagen ich bin gerade in berlin
wenn ihr das video seht ansonsten jahre
hier oben links geht's weiter mit
unserem letzten video von uns beiden
sollte das einblenden
20 36 auf den fahrer und ihre
feindschaft
manche ein bisschen zu ernst genommen
aber schaut mal vorbei und ja auch
schöne woche noch und sorry dass diese
woche nur ein video kommt aber dafür mit
mir und nächsten woche nächsten nächsten
wochen montag geht's wieder weiter